okay so i've been asked to do a how to
beat video for a while now
and what better way to start a new
series by being the man that talks about
the best way to murder everyone's
favorite female superhero
that should go down well with people yay
now normally these kind of videos center
around horror villains
but as this is mainly a comic book movie
channel i thought i'd tackle how to take
down one of the most popular in the
medium
wonder woman is a half god invincible
amazonian warrior
who either leaves you lost in a fight or
lost in her eyes
as beautiful as she is deadly she's
definitely not one for us mere mortals
to mess with
but there is a way for people like you
and me to be there you just have to want
it
throughout this video we're going to be
going through the best strategies for
taking her down
and because of this there may be some
spoilers in regards to wonder woman
1984.
if you're new to the channel then make
sure you subscribe for videos like this
each and every day
and don't forget to smash the thumbs up
button if you'd like to smash calcutta
if you like the video
without the way this is the heavy
spoiler show i'm your host paul
aka maxwell bored now let's get into the
breakdown
okay so the best way to completely kill
wonder woman is to put her in an 80s
movie
with terrible cgi and have jeff jones
write this script eh yeah you're having
that
no no i actually like the movie and with
the third one already greenlit
there are several ways that the villains
could take her out
we don't know who's going to be
featuring in it just yet but my guess is
that because of the asteria tease at the
end
that we may get some amazonian threats
now in order to talk about the route
you want to take we first have to talk
about batman endgame
by scott no not not not that
not that in game now the book opens with
batman being attacked by the justice
league
after we learn that the joker has
perfected his toxin so that it can
control the metahumans
the fight culminates with batman making
it to his justice buster suit
which is built to basically bring just
ice and i don't mean some crap mr freeze
puns however
batman actually manages to beat wonder
woman before getting to it
and this is because he uses an ancient
cerebral relic
known as the bind of veils in wonder
woman 1984
diana divulges that her lasso of truth
is literally powered by the truth
and in many ways her own power comes
from this
therefore lies are very much her
weakness and in the work we discover
that after creating it
hevastus had a moment of doubt and used
an inverted version of the fabric
powered by deceit
in order to create the bind it's said to
be made from the will of the sheep that
odysseus and his men used to trick the
cyclops
and it took bruce nelly two years to
track it down on the black market
in the comic books after the character
was killed by neron
she became resurrected as a goddess of
truth so we have this idea of the truth
being
tied heavily to the character eerily
that issue in which she was killed was
actually released on august 31st
1997 which is the same day that princess
diana who shared her name died in a car
accident very
very strange anyway back to the topic at
hand as we've been saying
wonder woman is very much seen as the
embodiment of the truth
and her latest movie even ends with her
using this idea
in order to defeat maxwell lord thus the
best way to beat her is through the
power of lies
and bruce manages to do this in endgame
by making her believe that she's one
so that the amazonian goddess gives up
the fight
however we want to kill her not just
subdue her
and in order to do this we have to build
upon this previous strategy
and stick with batman who developed
another way to take her down
what a great mate now in justice league
tower of babel
we discover that batman actually
developed contingency plans for the
entire league
just in case any of their bevo went
broke i'm telling you this
look this lad now this story was loosely
adapted in justice league doom
and in both versions bruce had a pretty
big thing in place for the princess of
the amazons
whereas in endgame bruce had her believe
that she'd won
in babel and doom he actually made her
hallucinate that she was facing an
opponent
that would not die every person she came
across had the face of her enemy
and because diana was trained to never
give up she attacked everyone she came
across
which along the other members of the
league diana fought them too
and turning the league on her is a
strategy so slick
that zemo would probably jump over from
the mcu to give you a high five
diana won't let herself lose no matter
what
and our plan would be to let her
literally exhaust herself until she died
either due to cardiac arrest
or was weak enough so that we could
sweep in with our next plan
that is to strangle her yes yeah i
really i realize we're going a bit over
the top here but look yeah
i like her but you wanted blood yeah so
in a way it's your fault
anyway in joker issue 10 we actually saw
something along the lines of this
when the clown prince of crime turned
her own lasso truth against her
and used it to hang the character you
see the lasso of truth
though diana's most trusted weapon is
also one of her biggest weaknesses
as said in 84 the weapon is bigger than
she is
and it's capable of killing her if used
correctly
so when when she's lying there exhausted
are you listening mate
talking about serious stuff here when
she's lying there exhausted
you need to slide in and use her own
lasso against her to hang her from the
statue of liberty
or wherever but make make sure you put a
banana peel there so she slips on it
because that definitely needs to be part
of the the issue
yeah i i still can't believe dc had one
of the greatest superheroes of all time
caught in a banana peel but
things were different back then now my
virginity hasn't grown back fully yet
so i thought i'd give you just one more
tip in case things come down to it
if she's still hanging in there
and you can use the powerful weapon of
the gods against her
and these have been known to kill her in
the past in the new 52 earth 2 vol
1 book diana was actually killed by
steppenwolf who thrust his gigantic
sword through her back
this not only killed the character but
it also allowed steppenwolf to murder
both superman and batman
i definitely recommend you check out
that run as as it's a great twist on the
original new 52 one
but just in summary if you ever need to
kill wonder woman
here's what to do grab a banana from a
fruit bowl at your house
or from a local fruit salesman available
in all good towns
use an ancient relic that took two years
to track down on the black market
to make her think she's fighting all the
movie critics and fans that said wonder
woman 1984 was the worst movie they'd
ever seen
probably a couple of million there which
will completely wear her out
and make her exhausted then when she's
down sneak in and grab the lasso of
truth from her
swing it over the statue of liberty
which pro probably
gonna be there when you you're fighting
i'm guessing eat said banana from before
and then use the peel to make her slip
off the statue where she'll swing back
and forth
then using something from another world
a weapon maybe order it on wish or
something but allow three weeks for it
actually don't use wish because it's
terrible but but get it from somewhere
yeah
and then just stab her and see it is
easy as that
you could also annoy her by saying did
steve trevor tell you that
and just being the worst friend in the
world basically
there are also older versions of a
cannon in which he's literally made out
of clay
and though this has been retconned
slightly you could try your luck with
getting her really wet
just show her a picture of me yeah now i
don't even think getting
clay wet will work i i just saw it in
ghost which
in some ways is a bit similar to the
plot of wonder woman 1984.
anyway that's how to kill wonder woman
mate hope this helps and yet
don't don't share this video with anyone
especially not warner brothers as
they'll think i'm a psychopath
and definitely not gal gadot because i'm
actually planning on pretending that
steve trevor has possessed my body so
that
so that she'll go out with me it's all a
bit cringy and will probably ruin the
entire channel if this gets out mate so
so cheers yeah cheers cheers yeah now i
appreciate you keeping it hush
and as a thank you i just want to let
you know that on the 30th of december
we're giving away three copies of the
lord of the rings 4k
box set to our subscribers all you have
to do to be on the chance of winning is
like a video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on how to
killer
the links to our socials are in the
description and you can also support the
channel by clicking the join button and
as a thank you you get videos like this
early
we've also just created an instagram
account which will be posting easter
eggs theories and a lot more
so make sure you get following now if
you want something else to watch then
check out our breakdown of wonder woman
1984 which will be linked on screen
right now
we go over the entire movie and talk
about how it links in with the comics as
well as its ending in post-credits scene
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want something else to watch
without the way thank you for sitting
through this psychotic video
i've been poor let's see you next time
take care peace